we've just had some remarkable uh
remarkably open information from moscow
on what they believe phase two of their
invasion or their limited military
operation as they call it will look like
they have said that once they capture
the donbass this large area in the far
east of ukraine that will give them a
land bridge to crimea
they say that they will encircle
mariopol the city that we've talked
about for so long and then that they
will push west that they hope to create
a land bridge to transnistria now
transnistria is to the north west of
odessa it's part of moldova a separate
country but it is a breakaway part of
moldova which is already aligned to
russia now this is really interesting
stuff transnistria already has a a unit
we of around about a thousand russian
soldiers who are based permanently there
combine that with with transnistrians
who are aligned with russia as well and
there is for putin a friendly force
within that breakaway part of moldova
so this is pretty alarming stuff i think
it um
it's worth remembering that what putin
intends to do and what he is capable of
doing are two different things and that
much has been proven uh by the
disastrous uh efforts that the uh that
the
russians had when they tried to take
kiev in the early stages of this war but
i've just spoken to sources in casino
the capital of moldova and they
confirmed what what i've discovered when
i was there a few weeks ago which is
that moldovans are very very nervous
they believe that if putin has the
ability to push into transnistria or
indeed to moldova proper then he will
moldova is not a member of nato uh it um
it feels at the moment very vulnerable
indeed so this this plan appears to be
to create a land bridge right across the
south of the country uh to isolate
cities like odessa uh and mariopol and
meritopol as well those cities along the
south
and and create this land bridge as i say
the the the the will is there the
ability of the russians to do that well
well perhaps not
and mark you're talking to us from
zaparizia what is the situation on the
ground there
well this is the town where all those
who are trying to escape those cities in
the south of the country uh um try to
get to they try to get into
ukraine proper territory that is not
occupied by russia and they are arriving
in dwindling numbers it has to be said
because it is harder and harder to get
out and what struck us here is that
nowhere's safe in ukraine there were air
raid sirens through the course of the
day yesterday we haven't actually heard
any today or at least i haven't i think
there have been a couple um but the
missiles that the russians are firing
are hitting towns like this as well we
visited a sanatorium here on on an
island that is in the middle of the
river that that cuts this city in half
that was hit yesterday by a russian
cruise missile eight people were injured
the railway line runs very close to that
sanatorium over the island and we're
told by the ukrainians that at the time
an evacuation train was on that track
and that the windows were smashed in
by the cruise missile that hit nearby we
don't know why the russians decided to
strike that particular point there is
military on the island
but it just gives a sense that nowhere's
safe in this country at the moment